[Music]
uh
i i need i need to be she's thinking
bobby she's thinking brandon job for the
breakup
yeah i swear to god
it's been uh a long not a long time but
like the last year it's been in
deliberation it's been on the table
right do we do we not and then you guys
have been privy to that except that
everyone else has the other one gonna be
like oh my vagina am i right oh my
vagina wait i know what everyone's gonna
do
yeah
oh you nailed it
privy to that a little bit so they need
to catch up we need to catch it right
right so when like the whole brendan
schaub thing happened he was like funny
it's like the rare times esther talks
somebody should be like hey hey calm
down
wow you're calm down you're derailing
the show
don't make this about yourself can you
stop derailing the show every two
seconds she was a marine huh yeah it's
very odd right you wouldn't think
not a lot of her people
statistically serve in the military look
i'm not i'm trying not to be mean but
what is this look what look is this what
the old canadian tuxedo no it's not a
canadian tux it's not just a canadian
tuxedo she's caught she's doing an
orange cassidy cosplay
she looks like she's about to be
impregnated by kyle reese
that's what she's dressed like
she might be
what is this look man
everyone's dressed like they're from the
cast of stranger things now like i don't
understand this
stranger things
right right so when like the whole
brendan schaub thing happened he almost
haven't heard of him
like forced it out of us even though we
weren't ready to talk about it and we
want to thank him for that thank you so
thank you that feels really sarcastic
right i feel like it's super sarcastic i
guess like in in a sense like you know
it that was a blessing in disguise
because it really
like forced us to like tackle head-on
because i think we would have taken much
longer to deliberate
you think she's got a text that says
yobe you single now
how long do you think he waits
he already did
and this sort of pushed it right in the
forefront of our like thoughts and
consciousness um by the way i just want
to point out while brian callum you're
really missing out on all these cool
friends you could be hanging out with
yeah i know yeah you're really missing
out on all these cool people that you
could be hanging with i don't know why
all these people just betrayed me now i
don't have any real friends is this who
you want to hang out with did it to
dalia business um
yeah
it's rewind time
um
on march 3rd
you text bobby asking if he's handled
the quote-unquote kalila [ __ ] yet
because you're still getting negative
comments in this text chain you said i
don't want to have to get nasty with her
but if i have no choice
this is all direct quotes i can def play
that game and this was referring to the
months that bobby and i were in an open
relationship
thinking that that was somehow going to
directly hurt me yeah obviously
obviously i mean it's like you know the
open relationship
you and i we we were that's not
for the was for the we even talked about
it's not about consumption right because
it was delicate it was a delicate thing
he was also
back on drugs
man she
will throw
anyone under the bus about any little
thing a heartbeat
in a heartbeat i mean not even like
it's one thing like if somebody like
caves and throws you under the bus but
like
there's no pressure required she's just
waiting she's chomping at the bit to
throw people under the bus so many
different elements elements to it right
it was a dark time it was very fragile
so it was you know we actually broke up
for a while yes in fact schultz knew
that because when schultz came here
so you did break up for a while but
earlier you said that brandon was the
reason you broke guys your entire you
keep complaining about people knowing
about your personal life but every
single show all you seem to talk about
is your personal life
why yeah do you have stuff to talk about
other than your personal life
like the crap